even after 30 years in the business
Goldsmith role suring still loves his
work he works for a jeweler in Stuttgart
but he designs his pieces himself quite
is this shrinks tomorrow yah a gold is
the finest material there is Dean by
it's incredibly malleable so you can
forge your fantasies and stretch it and
the greatest thing of all is once you've
worked it up I filed it out and then
polished it it Justin gleams and glows
in this magnificent way clapping clance
as you can see here the optic editions
heed the jeweler next door to his shop
offers his creations for sale the
individual pieces most of them of gold
started 4,000 euros now the price of
gold has plunged but the customers here
won't feel the effects anytime soon
listen in our business the trends are
most often long-term not short-term come
on but you're happy about it of course
because if prices stay low we'll have a
broader customer base and our
Goldsmith's can work at their full
potential and make pieces heavier again
it's really nice for creative people not
to have these constraints does this
forget evil ordinateur accessissue
invented an abstraction many people in
stood guard on the lookout for ways to
invest their money for the long term
precious metals dealer pro Aram was so
confident in the market that they opened
a new shop downtown where investors can
buy gold bullion as bars or coins the
big eye catcher here is a gold coin
denominated at 1.3 million euros buyers
who've made it this far usually have a
clear idea of how much they want to
spend and only want advice which coin is
the most advisable to purchase this
woman paid some nine thousand euros for
this bar that's when i finish combo are
more people coming in now that the price
of gold is so low rashmi are quite a few
more than in the weeks before this is a
good level both to jump in or to top up
off to stop Gold is a hot topic at the
investors fair a couple of kilometers
away some of them have brought along
their entire savings and the gold
dealers have bullion ready to sell right
here at the fair
torsten protal is a specialist in
precious metals at the barden rutenberg
state bank the sudden drop in the price
of gold didn't surprise him the analysts
was well aware that there was just too
much gold on the market it's a bit swing
by the European Central Bank made Cyprus
sell its gold reserves while the US
would rather put less cash into the
market than before those are all factors
investors hadn't recognized so many are
selling off their positions now at the
same time many small investors see an
opportunity to jump into the gold market
many Germans are worried that their
savings are no longer safe in the bank
they're buying gold instead will mind
even if my motive isn't so much to find
a safe place for my money but more
something for the longer term that gives
me greater financial freedom I'd say if
you're going to buy a gold now is the
time so terriots coffin why I think the
price of gold is dropping like a rock
but it's still too high
yeah even so it's my opinion that now is
the best time to buy the state banks
analyst degrees he says the traditional
savings account isn't what it used to be
yeah um actor LM OBT now we're seeing a
run on gold investors are storming the
banks in many places that bigger gold
bars are sold out while others can only
be hand with markups so the drop in
price has prompted many small investors
to buy but bigger investors are still
skeptical larger players like the
pension funds and foundations are
waiting or even selling their gold yeah
boy unlock all frozen the Goldsmith has
put this chain together in just eight
hours he's still got to set the gemstone
it will go on sale for some 10,000 euros
a splendid gift and a sound investment